on March 5th 2012 film courage calm had
the opportunity to attend a press
roundtable interview with the two stars
of salmon Fishing in the Yemen Emily
Blunt and Ewan McGregor this audio is an
excerpt of this press day for more
information on the film please visit
Fishing in the Yemen calm just nod and
smile and Chinese I had a very nice
Chinese lady teacher came came round to
my flat and she she had translated it
from the script script I just had it in
English and it simply said in brackets
she speaks this in fluent Chinese and I
was like I guess I have to learn
Mandarin us at some point and Laster was
incredibly laid-back about the idea no
no no no we shoot this in two weeks is
going to take me some time like we
should probably learn this he went oh
yes we should probably get on this so
lay back
so yeah this woman came around she just
I learnt it phonetically so I know
nothing about how to say hello how are
you but I do know how to talk about
salmon she nailed my wife speaks giant
mandrel and she said she did a very very
good job and it was very complex all the
tones and I was very interesting do you
think one day I've got to do a movie
about salmon transplantation yeah yeah
it's a goal for many many young
especially shots are always looking for
salmon fishing movie
you think that could be a hurdle to
audiences and what would you tell them
that yes there's something in this movie
for everyone I don't know I don't but I
think the titles very literal and it's
it's a film about salmon Fishing in the
Yemen it's called salmon Fishing in the
Yemen I think it's interesting it's not
the run-of-the-mill kind of title so it
should pique some interest and I think
we're doing an enormous amount of press
so that people hopefully by the time
they hear the siren we're on television
talking about it it's a lovely thing to
learn to do I mean it's a beautiful and
it's really act like the top knowledge
of fishing because it's particular
you're you - you're trying to catch only
fish that feed from the surface and
generally you do it very beautiful
places Norway Russia Scotland called
water places and it's all a fly
fishermen end up traveling a lot and
traveling - very beautiful remote and
air places so I think it's very good for
the soul yeah and the natural challenge
of it is as far as far harder to catch a
fish that way so it's quite its
spiritual I think in a way it's nice I'm
not
whenever I'm gone fishing I've gone
fishing very rarely but for those
reasons you know to be quiet and to
contemplative and be somewhere beautiful
and yeah the actual catching of a fish
is something I'm not really interested
in and you just got really seasick when
you weren't fishing yeah I just I'm not
I mean my experience fishing when I was
younger was that my dad would who loves
to do the deep-sea fishing you know we
have to go way out which also means huge
waves it's particularly off the coast of
the UK and so we would go off the coast
of Scotland and Cornwall and you know
dad would put these eight hour fishing
trips and we'd come back you know the
color of your shirt you know just be
just so ill and
and I just be hurling off the side of
the boat the whole time I don't have a
good sea legs good legs ya know kinda
absolutely yeah another challenge like
you know going back to your roots and
kind of rediscovering a proper Scottish
I mean I've made a lobster I've made
four movies in Scotland um and the and
five actually never including this one
so it wasn't there's no great sense of
like rediscovery or like a homecoming
for me because I go there every year you
know I mean I'm I'm attached to Scotland
in the heart and I love it
so I I didn't have to sort of rediscover
it but I did shoot monster films I've
made are and I've been in Glasgow which
is an amazing city but we shot right up
in the highlands right in the heart of
the highlands and it is absolutely
majestic up there is beautiful so that
that was kneelin and when you're filming
you do have lots of time to hang around
because you know so it's quite nice to
hang around just looking up at the hills
and I liked it very much been back there
it was lovely
it was very important is special to me
in that respect and and I worked in and
that into my character to Alfred who's
not in the novel isn't Scottish he's not
written as a Scotsman and I felt very
strongly when I read the script that he
could be and that it would help if he
was and then when I met Simon he
encouraged me to use this accent there's
morningside accent which is very uptight
Edinburgh acts and kind of a little bit
full posh and then I wasn't sure about
it and then I first met Emily we've met
in the rehearsal room with NASA and I
was telling her that I didn't know
whether to use does accent or not she
said let me hear it so we read a scene
eventually you've got to use that accent
changed you completely it's done and I
think that's what is really nice I think
that's what I like about all the
physical aspects of from you know
creating a part and it is important
voice and the way you
how does this character feeling your
skin how would she how would she said
how could she do that what would she
feel you know I mean you want to feel
them in your bones a little bit so I
think changing your voice like that I
just did something to everything value
it was crazy
it was good cool so that was nice and
then when were in the helicopter going
back you know I all of the my job is to
sort of unpeel Alfred from this rock at
the beginning reason alot up so we're in
the helicopter about Scotland remember
we came up with some classic you know
some terrible dialogue for us to Sarah
like well no he should say he hasn't
been home for a long time so for Alfred
it really is like here's the first layer
coming off and we're where he succumbed
of his element out of the officer of his
scientific you know miserable marriages
in highland scotland for the first time
in a long time and and and he's and then
he gets sent off fishing by the the
sheikh very cleverly tells him tells his
partner to send them fishing we see him
fishing we see that he's different least
he's slightly calmer and nicer no no no
it was nice it's nice to do it up there
it's nice that's two guys to go massive
change or a death yeah yes no I don't
know I'm I don't know because I don't
know what what everybody's got different
rocks yeah different ways of getting out
well I'm already and already in a rut so
I'm in a profession that means oh for
Alfred yes like what did you learn
watching him like I see well I was very
it was a very slow it was a very slow
process of like peeling back the layers
and for him it meant change it meant and
ultimately you know leaving his marriage
and it meant you had wonderful melting
haughtier it means melting haughtiness
hope you observe a fashion thing I don't
know actually
lovely melting culture
H a ute you are that's a lovely thing to
say thank you well you could chart the
progression of your character by how
well comb his hair was well know that
was very important I mean that's
absolutely a tool you use costume makeup
hair at the accent softens is good
through so at the beginning is much more
up towards accent by the end it's not
near as much softer and your hair was
absolutely so those are all tools to do
that to make that work and you look in
the mirror and just lay back and bill
condon was originally set to direct it
cast the two of you sir was it when lass
comes on what kind of is laid back great
for you was it different than what you
would work with before how did it work
it doesn't mean in the sense that he you
know he doesn't care about about these
aspects but I think I think Nasser is
incredibly collaborative and I think
he's very open and I think he's willing
to let you find it and you play with it
and I think he works quite similarly to
how you and I like to work which was a
relief that he likes to keep things
fresh and spontaneous and so going into
a scene how it was on the page usually
wasn't how it ended up when we started
doing it and that's that's a real joy
when you can stretch a scene around and
make it and go down different little
parts that you didn't expect and but you
know lasses he's really a quirky
dude he's really hard in the most
wonderful way any almost place still can
get a read on him because he only plays
the part of the buffoon it's always
making silly jokes and tripping
self-activate strips like he plays the
part of a clown to soar to diminish his
position on set I think he wants to
apart the gang he doesn't want to you
know be seen to be the one with all the
answers because I think he likes to see
them unravel for themselves you know I
all great directors he stands in the
middle of a great many brilliantly
creative people only less them all work
to their best and he just kind of he
gently kind of wrangles that but he he
lets everybody excel and then pour pour
inexperienced directors are the ones who
feel that they have to make every single
decision and everything has to go
through them and they just stand here
everyone gets straitjacketed you know
which is not which is not pleasant but I
think when you want in a director is a
point of view and you also want that
kind of openness and for them to install
some kind of confidence in you but I
think a point of view it is is important
I do like Simon I mean I think they're
unbelievably interesting in terms of
their lifestyle
I mean to age no no I know I'm coming to
that science in there down the coast of
Scotland they turn left up the river
they were born on howdy and they go back
to where they were born to spawn and
then they die I think they're really
fascinating thing about chase people in
the morning
I thought fantastic turtle story it's
amazing you know the mummy Topher comes
up the beach and she is a joke like down
the beach a lot of them don't make it
and allowed them do it at night when
there's less birds and stuff you know
telemeter probably I don't know probably
like a 1/8 of them actually make it
maybe less
tenth we go out to sea and years and
years later
when they're ready to be mommy turtles
they come back to the same beach it's
not a smoked salmon are partial to water
so first thing good morning better bags
what did you lazy thing I was cold it
was an illustration along stones we're
trying to make it look very the best
action we did in the movie
we would be getting into the work into
the stream you know we'd be kind of
walking in like that and the desert
climate just plummets at night I mean
it's freezing and your whole body would
just be like that and then we did the
last minute plunge in some we'd be like
that and everything in your body is
fighting the chapter to not you know
what happened to say it's wonderful I
feel like I sound really strange I think
that's why I have a king of action be
Jack the giant-killer trailers and we
see a little bit of your night in that
do you have a lot more action we're
gonna see I haven't obviously I built it
sure that I've seen a naked Nick there's
a lovely a very nice lickle T's very
talented young boy yeah um we well what
was the question why am I not on the
trailer I don't know
they want to sell a phone or not no idea
I just saw a hope that it'll be fine
selling this demo I don't know it's the
nice son
it's a lovely film love to see some of
loop ER when they release trailers for
that yeah what kind of part do you have
in that is that researcher I'll play a
very tough Kansas farm girl is that the
one of the shotgun loose end the pitch
off or pretty cool it's pretty cool and
I don't know how much I could say about
Luka actually I'm sort of sworn to
secrecy on that one because there's a
lot of complex twists and turns in it
but it's a very cool tightly woven
thriller you know and set in an
incredibly real way in this futuristic
backdrop it's just really is in the
future yeah it's like 2030 okay like
2014 describing about publicity stunts
how you guys see the actors I think well
I don't think first of all I don't our
films about and there's an app you know
there's the element of the publicist
that British bombers publicist spinning
everything and I think in terms of
politics that's an absolute reality so
we're constantly fed you know I do
name that they're called spin-doctor
silver it's like professional liars you
know to take facts that they don't want
us to not know about and spin them into
something else and I think the tabloids
are playing either we are liars and so
but I would hate to think of our the
shake sadly isn't and isn't isn't the
the salmon project and the eminence
isn't a publicity stunt it's what he
really believes in and it's a very true
passion of his and that he's not using
for publicity reasons he does it because
he believes in everything no I just
think when she was saying how how do you
how do we feel about the media and how
you know mistakes the media do I don't
know I mean I think I think a lot of the
tabloids are professional Liars really
and I think story is a you know created
and in a very reckless way nowadays you
know when it comes to penises of
people's lives that you're talking about
and so I do think it's definitely
getting worse in a sense the media when
it comes to people in the public eye I
guess for people who are you know in
this sort of profession but yeah it's
better not to breed anything yeah I just
gave it a go because these two persuaded
me I should I don't try to be happy
scene by the fireplace in our scope yeah
come on isn't have any wellington boots
on fine and he was like come on it'll be
fun and he has this lovely little dog
said who's just our friend I love that
dog so much and yeah that's very
effective yeah I don't think it wouldn't
be nice to be whipped across the Olaf
life
like Hitler
kind of sort of a combination really
it's not tend to pick out specific
moments or anything it just either leaps
out to you and speaks to you in a way or
it doesn't and and I just loved it I
loved it in the first 10 pages I loved
it I thought it was so funny and had
such wet you know I think I wasn't so
cool about it it felt different and
that's always a good thing you know we
were excited about that a chance that
the Star Wars movies are coming out
again in three days almost on
starwars.com I was excited about it in
terms of there being another there's a
generation of kids that didn't see in
the cinema you know and then because I
think the first one came out you know
there's a whole generation of children
that didn't get to see it in the cinema
it's just nice that they get the chance
you kids don't care that no really but
they but they but kids love it I mean I
think that's the one of the things that
was easy to forget and I I I come across
everyday with friends kids and people
are mean streets kids and the absolute
passion for the Star Wars movies that
they have is is it's exactly what we had
when we watched them when we were kids
you know
and I was like oh it's one of the quotes
you know it just depends upon if you're
traveling it'll be someone on a plane or
and it's lovely because you know those
lines that I was given in that film
we're just heaven and that's why I love
playing that part it was just it was
wonderful so I don't like to say
well I'm not gonna celebrate a million
I'm gonna be skiing I think probably I'm
gonna be skiing and I've got four kids
when we were doing some fishing we both
separately without telling each other
head started doing Bikram yoga which was
really weird and then the office could
be living on other there's no that he is
there kind of it's the teaching styles
of this straight come on what came it's
a relaxed